I don't care about what people say like
I'm like I said it falls on deaf ears
with me but I am gonna prove you wrong
though coming up in this sport I've
never had a skill but I had a wheel I
had heart I had determination you
weren't gonna beat me there's a
possession of powers real you know it's
very real sometimes scares me and I'm
the one possesses it need motivation
watch the top 10 with believe nation
what's that belief nation it's Evan I
believe in you and this channel is
designed to be a part of your daily
success routine so let's get your
motivation to attend and get you
believing in you grab a snack and chew
in today's lessons from a man who went
from dreaming of becoming a basketball a
football player but the birth of his
daughter who had a spinal disorder made
him quit those activities to focus on
her and his boxing career to him
becoming a heavyweight champion he's
Deontay Wilder and here's my take on his
top ten roses success also if you learn
from Muhammad Ali Floyd Mayweather Ray
Lewis and others check out my 254 black
excellent series where every day for the
next 254 days I will send you a mourning
video for free shining a light on
excellence in the black community the
link to join is in the description below
well last week I murdered a rock into
the stone hospitalized a brick I'm so
mean I make medicine sick jealousy
people jealous of you cuz what success
so anything is successful it only Josie
okay let's pick it up with rule number
one prove them wrong don't say after the
Olympics in 2008 you'd be criticized
even though you won bronze some people
said that you were wild and you weren't
gonna achieve in the pros how much of
that was an incentive to drive you I
mean really all of it you know I come
from a place where I've always heard
different things I've always heard what
I can't do
I've always heard what I don't need to
be doing I need to be doing this instead
of that
you know all the negativity I've been
brought up and raised you know through
our society hearing different things
that I'm not gonna achieve so you know
it's a big booster for me because I love
prove people wrong
please welcome 2008 US Olympic bronze
medalist
[Applause]
once I got it till my 15 fight you know
knocking guys out I start something can
everyone out and then I started and must
have some you know I must got some here
and then it just start being even more
confidence booster for me because I'm
continuously consistently knocking these
guys out over and over and over again
someone just like that it's like this
ain't nothing fake this is no fluke this
is nothing in here no blood this is
actually real
[Music]
people say that you're this wild guy
they said the same about Marciano he
didn't have a whole load of technique is
that something that bothers you when
people say that I'm a dime bother me at
all I don't care about what people say
like I'm like I said it falls on deaf
ears with me but I am gonna prove you
wrong though you know and that's what I
do
rule number two master the mind
this is powerful this right is very
powerful people to understand they think
I just talk crazy just to talk it you
know me I always talk about meditation
it's a powerful thing and one day
everybody's gonna be talking about it
once they master it and learning and see
what it benefits you in your life mmm
so every fight this right here carried
me through coming up in this sport I've
never had a skill but I had a wheel I
had heart I had determination you
weren't gonna beat me I didn't see it
nor did I felt that energy rule number
three master your craft you don't appear
to be hiding anything you know you're
not withholding on any information about
tactics or anything is is that not a
thing for you you don't go into it
tactically you think about the knockout
I don't really think about the knockout
you would think so because I'm good at
knocking you out you know me but now you
know I don't really I don't think about
the knocker as much as people would
think I would you know I can't be in the
ring and just think about I've tried
that before earlier in my career and it
didn't come as fast as I wanted to now
when I took my mind off of that then
that's when it happens you know I mean
so you have to set it off you have to do
a lot of little things you got to follow
the rules you know you just can't going
in just hear somebody and think you
gonna knock them out it don't work like
that
it definitely takes the science it takes
a skill to be able to do that and I'm
I've mastered that you know especially
the ones who are nicer to death I could
throw one - so clean you would never see
the right hand come
you can try to but when they hit you
that when you go know when you wake up
and your people tell you it's over and
you're gonna be like wait a minute I am
here to cut the rough count you were
gone man you got knocked out rule number
four be your own boss I've always been
the type of person that felt like I
supposed to be a boss I supposed to be
working for myself I suppose that I've
always had that feeling you know
sometimes you get you know many people I
know many people to this day that
haven't made it yet but they're well on
their way and what they're doing and
they had the same feeling they feel like
they don't you know you get that it's a
it's a certain feeling you get like you
don't enjoy nothing that you're doing
because you're working for someone else
doing it ain't like feeling like freedom
you know I'm saying like you got a BA by
someone else ruin you put money and
someone else pocket when you can put in
your own like I've always felt that way
I always feel like I should be my own
boss rule number five be yourself
there's a couple of quotes that have
gotten you I don't know if you consider
it to be trouble but I've certainly
certainly raised eyebrows you know the
wanting the body on your record the most
recently one the crippled Brazil in
front of his son what are those kind of
comments come from where are you in your
head when you say make those kind of
comments I feel at the moment you know
how about delivery and how people may
take it didn't that's their business you
know I mean like I said I do my job my
job is to fight hmm and I do that no
matter how much you should love a person
that can get in front of camera express
to you how they feel and show aggression
but not only to aggressing but through
how I how I speak you feel what I say
even when you look me in my eyes and I
speak to you I mean what I say you mean
those things literally I'm this is
marching this is a sport this is this is
this is not a gentleman sport I don't
ask you can I hit you in your face nor
do you ask me this you may be on the
outside but even on the outside like I
said before you must be cautious at all
times because you should never know what
hungry shot we're gonna come up in your
territory you never know who long
who's coming around you gotta be careful
at all time the gentleman thing goes so
far this boy is a this boy right here is
a gladiator sport this sport right here
will get you hurt badly seriously okay I
can play the nice guy I played the nice
guy before what did he give me no way
I'm not playing no bag I'm not playing a
villain that just how people make me out
to be because they don't understand me
all I could be who I am
I only be hoody on say wow there is and
who I am rule number six be confident
every fight you bring a different person
I'll you why because styles make fights
everybody don't have to stay in style
and I know me I'm the most awkward
fighter in the division you think Tyson
fear are greater than you see you ain't
see yeah you know that's what they'll
make it an intriguing fight because our
spouse is so crazy it may complement
each other you just never know you know
but unfortunately think about theory
that he don't have power and I think
this is a possession of powers real you
know he's very real sometimes scares me
and number one possesses in it I don't
know when I'm gonna get you I'm gonna
get you and when I do old boy dying baby
good night rule number seven be
passionate when you're in that moment
that place in the ring you're not a nice
guy not only do the person I am on the
outside change but the person on the
inside the feeling that I have been
inside it changed too
what is it it's a feeling that I cannot
describe you know I try to find words I
try to take my mind away and describe
even even when we talk about the
fighting I really I feel them right now
rule number eight never give up if I
would you know giving advice on box I
tell them to
to work hard train never give up don't
listen to the naysayers you know
sometimes we all have a we our own
biggest critic I tell people all the
time 110% sometimes we can give my wall
sometimes we can give 100% and still
fail and had come to destroy into the
stick but we give the extra team we got
a pretty good chance of folk coming
through with anything rule number nine
find your fuel there's all started from
a love of a father trying to support his
yo job you know I only got into boxing
because of my my daughter that was born
with spina bifida she came from a long
place she came yeah she came very far
you know from from what doctor said that
she would maybe never be able to do like
walk or or have a natural child ability
or learning but she's amazing she's
doing and she I'm so proud of my
daughter it allows me to continue to be
strong and in boxing you know it's like
we feed off each other strings push push
push push
there you go get back in there you go
now they're my motivations to everything
that's why I think ain't no man in the
square ring is gonna be able to beat me
because I wear my I bring my children
with me you know they'd stuck in my
heart I've already promised dinner and I
gotta keep my promise it ain't nothing
personal for no fighter in the industry
I want everyone to make money I want
everyone to be successful and have a
great life but when it comes to me I
bring something different you're not
just firing me
you know you find me plus my surgery and
rule number ten the last one before a
very special bonus clip is be willing to
lose it all this is gonna be a brief
light you know this is like I said
before this is the biggest fight in the
world right now if you're a fan of
boxing you something to be excited about
because you definitely got one champion
in this sport if not two but mostly you
definitely you got one chapter in this
book they're willing to prove to anybody
that he is the best and willing to put
whatever he got whatever he owns on the
line for it whether it's my old with it
so feel my belt my pride
whatever I'm willing to put it all on
the line for this very moment it's very
nice it's one fight you know it means
everything for me
I've got a special bonus clip from
Deonte on how to have a great team that
I think you're gonna enjoy but before
that it's time for the three-point
landing questions time to move from just
watching another video to taking action
in your life or your business and if
you're feeling bold leave your answers
in the comments below here we go
question number one what excuse are you
making that you're going to get rid of
number two who is under estimating you
right now and number three who do you
need to add to your team to make it
great
warrior and we're going to war war but
you know boxing is a war and it's very
physical and violent and we're basically
preparing for that Peter cornerman we
met a long time ago and um I consider
one woman were best I can't put one of
the world's best strength trainer in the
world you know we don't been together we
didn't saw each other grow we didn't
learn to each other and every time when
I my team you know every every member of
my team it's like I form meeting them I
have clicked and with Peter the same
thing when I first met him we click you
know I'm a super hard work worker but uh
when I had somebody just passing what
I'm doing it takes me it makes me want
to go to that level it makes me want to
see how far can I go when I reached my
level what I feel like I don't have
enough and I know that he got somebody
else push me like I got a little bit
more I can go the most important work
ever if you had to think of one word
that's most important to you or that
sums you Apple
that would be like a little beacon
[Music]
if you like this video check out the top
10 I did on Muhammad Ali I think you'll
enjoy the link is right there next to me
continue to believe and I'll see you
there
I don't pay no attention to what they
say about me I told you all that I was
the greatest of all time the my main
fight is for freedom and equality